[Music]
[Applause]
Brian Scalabrine Celtics analyst NBC
Sports Boston and he was with the
Celtics when they won it all in 2008 the
white Mamba and uh scalabrini says the
Celtics have no excuse not to win a
championship this year he joins us now
but if they don't win the championship
it will be because of what or who Brian
I don't know about who but I'll tell you
if uh their their roller coaster ride
maybe not kick in the regular season
seriously I mean right now you look
around the NBA and everyone is like
flipping a switch the Laker slip to
switch the the Golden State Warriors are
flipping the switch you know Miami Heat
flipped the switch so the Celtics may be
playing with fire right there but you
know like you see him in game one you
realize you guys got to play a lot
harder if you're gonna win then you
watch them in the third quarter of game
two and you realize what their potential
is yeah I they're they feel like they're
not threatening some nights it's weird
to watch a team that's that talented but
then they know show sometimes yeah and I
why I I don't think they understand how
difficult it is and how hard you have to
play by the way you could see this if
you watch the the Knicks play the Miami
Heat in game two it was almost like the
Knicks didn't realize well Jimmy
Butler's not out there let's just Coast
to victory yeah it's just not like that
and I think the Miami Heat right now in
the playoffs you look at them they work
every possession Eric spoch is doing the
same thing that's what it takes to win a
championship even when you have the most
Talent so I just like I'm sometimes
maybe surprised maybe it's habits
throughout the regular season we're
living in an era where the players don't
take the regular season seriously you
know in the past great players have been
able to flip a switch maybe these guys
feel like they could do it and they
clearly the Celtics did it from game one
to game two they went to a new level and
everyone will talk about adjustments Dan
sometimes it's just playing harder
pressuring the ball being in people's
airspace that's a big adjustment in the
NBA and sometimes when the star player
is not there you kind of exhale a little
bit and then Harden goes off and by the
time you realize he's going off you
can't stop him and you get steamrolled
there a little bit but with embiid
coming back how surprised were you that
he came back and he came back on the
road as opposed to staying in
Philadelphia they already got their
split sure and that's what I thought
maybe you just keep him in Philly yeah
so so Dan this is the way that I looked
at that particular game and I and I
would guess if I was in the meetings
with Doc Rivers he would say the same
thing so obviously game three is huge
right you got embiid hoisting the trophy
On Any Given night when you're going
through a series like Jimmy Butler
taking off game two after one it's
totally fine to get a couple recipes but
Dan and B need if he didn't play last
night he wouldn't have played for 13
days there's not like it's not more is
better on this one like you you're
eventually gonna have to play through an
injury two days is not gonna make that
big of a difference so I thought that
what Philly got out of that was and B
got a chance to kind of get his feet
underneath him because you got to expect
in game three Philly crowd late start
you know they need this at Boston Philly
hoisting MVP Trophies you don't want MB
to be coming off of a 13-day layoff so
the Celtics feel good about what they
got they got the they got back on track
in game two but Philly also feels good
we're getting our MVP back you know he's
gonna be he's gonna have his sea legs
Underneath Him and we're gonna have the
crowd behind us I think I don't think
there's been a a game in Philly right
now in about 12 days where now all of a
sudden or maybe it's 10 and all of a
sudden now that crowd is going to be
rabid so it's gonna be a really good
game three Brian scalabrini Celtics
analyst former player part of the 2008
championship team with the Celtics and
the white Mamba how did you get that
nickname
Stacy king that's how like uh he's the
uh he's the analyst for the Chicago
Bulls you know like he I made I made a
pair of shoes from Kobe and I slapped
him down on the table and yeah he
started calling me the white Mama since
ever since then did Kobe ever talk about
that so he reached out on Twitter and
you know welcomed me to Twitter White
Mamba that was only the only stamping of
the white Mamba from Kobe he gave me an
all-star jersey and he said to the white
Mamba
so maybe maybe maybe all of us maybe all
white guys I think he was complimenting
me by calling me that I I didn't you
know say I'm gonna call myself this but
I figured if Kobe co-signed on this or
signed off on it then literally then I
was I was pretty good but but you faced
all of these guys didn't you yeah I mean
Kobe was his shot making ability was is
off the charts like you know I think
it's very similar to what we're seeing
right now with the skill level of the
player it was an anomaly back then for a
guy go right go left step back right
step back left finish right finish left
like most guys had Tendencies to do five
things I went I had I had a matchup with
Kobe one day so I wanted to watch film
you know like so we have something
called Synergy you can get his last
hundred Clips he took 98 different types
of shots then I asked for another 100
clips and there was like 74 different
types of shots like I went into the game
like but what was the scouting report on
Kobe there is none I mean you know there
had to be yeah yeah like you were you
were more dialed into where your help
was coming from don't let him get to the
middle of the floor because we're not
gonna help you there you're gonna have
somebody on the Baseline it's more like
that it wasn't like I'm telling you I
could tell you Tracy McGrady and the
hesitation Vince Carter Paul Pierce they
all had about five or seven things they
did what about LeBron what did you try
to get him to do yeah so LeBron at the
back in the day hesitation right or when
he goes left he steps back so you kind
of want him not to get to his right hand
you know what made LeBron great back
then was his passing right and this is
all pre-championship Lebron like I'm out
of the league in 2012. you know I didn't
really play my last couple years it was
just kind of like the guy on the bench
so like you're not you're not getting
into a matchup where you're I'm like I'm
like not like Paul Pierce that has to
guard him you know 65 possessions or
he's going through you know 50 pick and
rolls but
um they all have like a tendency but
right now you look at Players much more
skilled in what we've ever seen like the
the curry effect that Damian Lillard I
mean you just go Shea gilgres Alexander
a guy didn't know anything talks about
yeah like these guys are so elitely uh
skilled and they don't have much offense
it's a weakness to their game what's it
like though when you're sitting on the
bench at the end of the bench and
sitting next to you is
a civilian
like some rich guy and he's sitting
right there with you oh do you talk to
him the funniest uh interaction I didn't
even know who the guy was we were in the
NBA Finals my rookie year and Brad Pitt
was that guy right I didn't know he was
Brad Pitt and he had like he was like
with the hit like you know you think of
Brad Pitt like I'm not dumb like Brad
Pitt's a great looking guy like you see
him on the movies like that this guy had
long hair he had a beard it was like it
was he almost looked like Forrest Gump
when he was you know running across the
country with you know he was just all
raggedy and he smelled like cigarettes
and I'm like I tell one of my teammates
like why the hell they let these guys
just sit here like that and my boy's
like you don't know who that is I'm like
ah he's like that's Brad Pitt I'm like
Brad Pitt from the movie Seven he's like
yeah that guy I was like oh what was he
filming that he looked like that I I
have no idea like he couldn't have
looked any worse put it that way
I had a bad experience an embarrassing
one at the Lakers game and I'm I'm
walking around you know I think I'm a
big deal at SportsCenter I'm walking
around you know right before the game
all the celebrities and then I see like
you know Justin Timberlake's there and
Brad Pitt's there I go up to Brad Pitt I
said hey Brad I'm Dan Patrick Sports
Center he has no idea who I am well I go
back and sit down and rich eisen's wife
was there next to me and uh she goes uh
hey you got a booger in your nose and I
go what
I I do she goes yeah I said oh my God I
just walked by Brett so Brad Pitt's
sitting down looking straight up my nose
yeah and he's got to be thinking that
guy had a booger in his nose man yeah
yeah no matter what he's not reaching
out and shaking your ass no no he's not
nice to meet you he's only thinking
about one thing at that point
uh who has more to gain from winning a
championship Steph or LeBron
you know I I think it's Steph Curry
because I think pretty much everyone in
the world at basketball had stamped
LeBron as it the best or the second best
and the Journey's still out like not for
me I think Steph Curry is an all-time
great like what is he top ten yeah top
five
he might be top five he might be like if
you don't
like if you can get past like
he's not gonna dunk on you he's not
gonna do that but like like he's an
assassin out there he's a killer like
he's a so Stephanie A Step Above Larry
Bird
yeah because of longevity yeah he's
gonna get me in trouble yes it is
like if Larry would have played
you know like if he would have kept on
going late and I mean didn't yeah Larry
Bird would be better but like longevity
does matter it's like it's the reason
why Lebron his numbers are going to be
off the charts so and I know like Steph
Curry's resting um you know you know
those those deprivation tanks and he's
got Bodywork people and all that you
know back in the day they they drink a
six-pack and smoked a cigarette like
that was their recovery do I get all
that but you you can't look at body of
work when you're talking about the
all-time greats and not factor in like
the longevity of it well that's why what
LeBron has done you know that he's got
the greatest resume in NBA history no
question right he does he might not be
the greatest player could Steph Curry
move past LeBron in your opinion
yeah with the championship
um this Championship you would put him
ahead of LeBron on the all-time I don't
know about that that'd be really that's
that's uh but but Steph's story if they
win again this year Dan this story is
not over
oh I know and then he would say look I
want another title without Durant
because we were like oh well Durant came
in you want a couple of titles wait
without him I mean I know anybody that
that uses that as an argument for LeBron
LeBron joined D Wade like I don't I
don't you can't if you have a problem
with the super team you can't pick and
choose which super team you have a
problem with you can't just say like I'm
okay with what LeBron did but I'm not
okay with what Steph did like you can't
do that you got to just have a problem
with all super teams and that's fine
that's your opinion but no I mean
Steph's story isn't done we don't know
he's not slowing down we don't know what
it's going to end like but his his
numbers could be not what LeBrons are
but I mean if he wins another
championship he has more championships
you can make the argument he's done it
with less I think the LeBron
championship in Cleveland was an
all-time great Championship like Kyrie
Irving Kevin Love Like like that was
really impressive for LeBron down 3-1
the Warriors 73 and 19. that that sort
of stamped the whole thing yeah you know
I don't really take a lot of stock into
the bubble championship
I think there's some variability into
that yeah but everybody was in the
bubble so it was a neutral neutral site
I know but when you're older and you get
four months off going into it you don't
have to travel and stuff like that I
think you have a little bit of an
advantage look at it I get it I get it I
just don't I I count it I just don't
count it as an all-time difficult one
but you know like I just I'm sure
somebody does that to Jordan when Jordan
beat the Lakers and Magic didn't play
got injured there nobody goes yeah but
you weren't facing you know a quality
Laker team
they did go on the road and beat the
Lakers and that's like beating Magic
Johnson's a big deal but magic was
injured
how injured was he I didn't he have like
the the thigh injury there oh I don't I
don't I mean it was in 91. but it feels
like we do this to LeBron
well the fact that Michael never lost
after he started winning every season he
started from 1990. okay but what
happened about the nine years where he
didn't get to the NBA finals
I mean that's you you factor that in but
I'm not I'm not holding LeBron's losses
against him I think people do though
Brian I think they're like yeah but he
lost I'm going you know are you going to
hold that against Tom Brady that he lost
you got to the Super Bowl you got to an
NBA Finals that's not a negative if you
lost Dan if if uh
if the Braun were to win this one would
you think that would be official stamped
I think he would be like I don't what do
you mean my opinion he would be the
greatest player of all time yeah my
opinion would be it won't happen though
Brian because people are holding on to
Michael Jordan's memories for dear life
they will not allow LeBron they will
I mean this this is why you're an
analyst Michael Jordan is pretty good
Dan Dan
do you want to retract the Larry Bird
stuff
funny that you said that it's funny how
you say that I will say this to retract
that I would say no one no one in the
NBA had three seasons Like Larry Bird so
I would say the back-to-back to back
MVPs you can't you can argue you'll take
those three seasons over anybody else in
the in the in the history of the league
but longevity does matter so I I can't
retract the longevity statement I mean
like you know Bill Walton why don't we
say Bill Walton's at all times he's not
I love him I love bill that one season
he had was amazing he was yeah that's
one season he was amazing he was
longevity does matter yes it does in the
NBA so good luck with that bird quote
there in Boston thanks Dan all right
thank you famous thank you Infamous
that's uh Brian scalabrini a fellow
White Mamba